ah we're on all right
what is this
all right
here now i just took off my um
air
because i've been listening to farsi
because i have a discussion at 11 with
my uh privacy or persian tutor
but i wanted to talk a little bit about
you know as we come to the end of the
90-day challenge
you know what has been my strategy here
now you know that
my 90-day challenge has been to learn
both
arabic and persian in other words to
improve in both of these languages
uh so that's perhaps not typical of most
of you who are probably focusing on and
on one language and i think i don't
think i'll do another 90-day
i shouldn't say that who knows what i'll
do but it's tough to do the two
languages so the strategy that i have as
i approached the end of the 90-day
challenge
is i said i would do a video in each of
the two languages
so
i decided about 10 days ago that i would
stop the persian
and focus on arabic for five days so
that i could then do my call it exit
interview
in
arabic
and if i had too much persian
interference it would make it much more
difficult so i focused on arabic
i increased the amount of time i was
spending on arabic
you know really working on it very hard
i don't know how many hours a day but
first of all i'm back in vancouver so i
don't have to go golfing every day i'm
not that keen of golfer uh golfing takes
up a good portion of the day which is
what we do in palm springs
so i was able to spend a fair amount of
the day
on my arabic and then i had my um
you know interview and one other thing
that i found very useful
is rather than trying to capture my
discussion on skype where the sound
level is different where the picture is
sometimes fuzzy where the connection is
sometimes poor i put my iphone on my
little tripod and so i just take a
picture of myself so that anyone who is
interested in watching my interview in
uh arabic
will mostly see me and hear me very
clearly and they'll hear the tutor in
the background
and i think that's a very good record
and uh
of my arabic now 90 day challenge
nearing the end at the end call it
and uh i've always felt and i want to
pursue this idea that
you know we should all have a sort of a
portfolio of of our progress in a
language or of where we stand in the
language and so this record
captured on my iphone or smartphone
android phone whatever
which focuses on me the learner
with the tutor in the background it's a
good record so if i do another 90-day
challenge on arabic which i may very
well do in the future
uh then
you know then i'll see how much i've
improved
so now of course i've shut off the
arabic and the last day or so and going
forward through the weekend and maybe on
on monday i have another discussion with
my person tutor i will do the same for
persia
and uh and by the way i have also in
this
dash to the finish line
uh i have increased the amount of
speaking i do
so um i want to get better at retrieving
what i have learned all the passive
vocabulary and so forth and i certainly
so uh leading up to my arabic
exit interview i think i had five
discussions
and there's no question that my fifth
discussion was better than my first
discussion and i've always said that
while input is how we
improve in a language to speak well you
have to speak a lot so if i wanted to
perform well in my exit
uh interview then i had to do more
speaking so i probably spoke five times
over a three day period which is much
more intensely than i normally uh speak
uh so you know if we look at that i you
know we're learning we're i'm learning
as a learner at link we're learning
we're learning about
the sort of the approaches we can take
towards
language learning and i think the 90-day
challenge is a really good thing to do
to me the the if people often ask you
know
how long does it take to learn a
language well of course that depends
entirely on what languages you know what
language you're learning and all this
but if i were just pick one number i
would say a year
one year all right so if a year
is sort of what the amount of time you
need to spend to kind of achieve
somewhere between b1 b2 depending on the
language a little longer a little
shorter
or at least to get the sense of
confidence that you're going to really
get there you know i think sometimes we
put too much importance on these levels
the important thing is to make that
breakthrough so that you're confident
you feel a sense of achievement you're
encouraged
and you feel you can just keep on going
in the language and i certainly feel
that way in arabic i'm not a
i'm barely b1 in arabic but i've you
know i had that feeling in that
conversation that i was understanding
everything
close to everything i was able to
express
what i wanted to express with mistakes
which the tutor corrected
and i'm on my way now unfortunately you
know i've decided i'm going to go to
ukraine i'm going to work on my slavic
languages so i'm going to put the arabic
and the persian on the shelf for a while
when i get back to it it'll take me a
while to bring back up what i've done
but it won't be lost and i'll be
eventually stronger than ever but so
it's a year well if one year is the sort
of
that's your mile that's your 1500 meters
you know it's a long distance run
uh you know
eventually it's a marathon but to get to
at least a decent level it's a mile
it's 1500 meters
1600 meters for the sake of calculation
so the 90-day challenge is a quarter
mile it's 400 meters so that's kind of
how i look at it so if you're focusing
on that period whereas normally you
might be running more slowly if it's a
marathon or even a mile but for the 400
meters you've stepped it up a notch it's
a 400 meter which is kind of between
all right
we're back i think i hope for whatever
reason the connection uh
disappeared
so as i was saying
so so the 90 day challenge is a 400 yard
dash or a 400 meter dash half dash half
distance
then this last dash to the finish line
is a sprint
so i really step it up all right i step
it up with the intention of having this
exit interview call it this discussion
with a tutor so that i can use my iphone
or android and create a record of what i
have achieved in these 90 days
so
the other thing i should point out is
you know i've often said that language
learning is like uh it's like a jigsaw
puzzle and the more things you put into
place the more things you have the more
new things you notice so as part of you
know now that i'm i'm working towards
this this exit interview a record of
what i have achieved in the 90 days
i'm not so interested in acquiring new
words i want to consolidate what i have
learned
so i review
obviously i've gone through uh you know
the mini stories i've gone through who
is she
and every time you listen to
very much
familiar material
you always notice something new
something that you hadn't seen before or
you hadn't noticed or you'd seen and
forgotten so it's very useful to review
in that way but i also review because
when i study a language i also buy books
and i recommend it i mean link is only
one tool
a powerful tool where i spend most of my
time but it's not the only thing i use
so for persian for example
this series here
living language
it has in their audio they have sort of
grammar exercises
now when i first listened to these
grammar exercises they made very little
impression on me
uh you know
the for example the subjunctive in
persian they have examples and you're
supposed to repeat which i never do
but now that i've seen this in action
so then i go back and i'm listening and
i went to the gym yesterday and i'm
listening and i'm cleaning up after
breakfast and i'm listening and of
course i hear a lot of things words that
i don't know
or aspects of the grammar that you know
it's very sort of um beneficial to hear
these things repeated now i want to go
back in and read again the other thing
is whether it be this book or my assimil
which i've gone through
or my colloquial version
whereas before i found it very difficult
to read
in the book
because
you know it's it's a new writing system
if i read a link i can well of course in
persian there's no text to speech but in
arabic there's text to speech but at the
very least i can look up every word and
see the meaning and then i can hear
right then and there i can then hear
the audio
but now i find that i'm much better able
to read just on a book so i'm getting
rid of my training wheels and i'm
starting to be able to read now granted
it's material that i've gone over before
but still i sense that increasing
ability to read in the new in the new
language so
you know all of this review
is very helpful and and i think the sort
of dash to the finish line of the 90-day
challenge might be usefully spent then
on review to consolidate what you've
learned
in the long haul i still need to acquire
far more words both in arabic and and
persian in arabic i i can't really
understand the political podcast that i
listen to i understand a third of it or
something so i need to acquire a lot
more words but having been through this
this 90 day challenge
and
this 400 yard dash i'm now approaching
the finish line so i crank it up and i
crank it up
more
in terms of reviewing what i've already
gone over and which i have forgotten
and trying to get that consolidated as i
cross the finish line
and then i have this exit interview and
i will do my exit interview in persian
probably on monday so that gives me the
weekend although i'm playing golf monday
every saturday and sunday but i hope to
have enough time to review persian so
that i don't do too badly in my persian
discussion on monday and that will be
the end of my uh 90-day challenge on
monday i'll review some of my statistics
and we can talk about all of our
experience
in
in the 90-day challenge so
with that i will now see what sorts of
questions we've got here
so
let's go to the top
yes
i'm from poland good evening from poland
from japan
you are a very good teacher thank you
hello good afternoon steve it's nice to
see you last week
you know is it possible for someone who
is not a native speaker of arabic to
become
uh
perfect
master arabic
you know i have no idea
uh i know lots of people who are
absolutely fluent in chinese and
japanese which are difficult languages
i consider myself very fluent in
japanese quite fluent in chinese
i can't see why
a non-native speaker of arabic couldn't
become very fluent in that language
i never consider you know speaking like
a native like 100 like a native i don't
see that as a realistic goal for most
people some people may achieve it but to
become very good in the language to
understand
very well to express one's self very
well i think that is very very doable
hi steve do you recommend doing
meditation to intensify i've started
doing and i feel much better okay
i don't do meditation so i can't comment
i have no experience with meditation so
there's very little i can say there mark
chavez hi steve what do you think about
giving people a medal or a badge or
something to people who reach different
mile zones in listening on a link i
think would be motivated
all right um we do have some kind of um
recognition on the website uh we could
probably do a better job mark i will
speak to
uh i will speak to uh mark and see we
can do
yeah que paso i see that's when that
suddenly my
uh internet connection went out and had
to re-uh
re-uh
connect here
good how difficult what german learning
books can you recommend
you know it's been so long since i did
german
but if i if you follow what i have done
with arabic and persian and greek and
romanian and all these languages uh
ukrainian polish whatever
fundamentally i use link i've i use the
many stories i feel that i keep on
stressing this but i in my own
experience the many stories have
tremendously accelerated
my learning because of the amount of
repetition because the how many times i
listen to them and so forth but i also
do get other books so get something
in your language if you're not an
english speaker you can get something in
whatever your native language is
sort of what i call starter books the
starter books and i i will usually buy
more than one
because the starter books cover more or
less the same material they have similar
content items you know at the airport at
the restaurant whatever introducing your
family
a lot of that is not very useful
vocabulary but it is content and then
they introduce some
basic concepts about the language which
we look at and forget it doesn't matter
but it's an introduction to the language
and i find that's a good companion to
link so what you choose to buy just go
into a bookstore or go to your library
and get something any starter book will
do and then work with link that's what i
would recommend
ah
hello my teacher how are you doing
learning hour very fast god save my
teacher do you know the line i have 500
names in arabic i don't know that
but i'm not going to learn them all
either
learning kanji before starting listening
and reading grammar was instrumental
even if you just learn directly i mean
it makes your language learning
enjoyable later on yes learn the kanji
like i i mean not before because it's
simply too boring to just do the kanji
so but
as a
a major initial effort in learning at
least
i don't know 500 a thousand kanji as you
are getting in you know introduced to
the language is very important and if
you can also be doing some basic
listening and reading you'll start to
recognize some of those kanji that you
are learning but the kanji learning is a
separate activity
it is reinforced by your listening and
reading but it needs to be a special
area of
uh concentration and within the first
three months let's say you should have a
thousand of them and for six months you
should have two thousand of them in my
opinion
steve can you recommend a book for
hebrew
uh
no i can't but
one of our members alisa from israel has
added a bunch of interesting stuff on
hebrew in our
hebrew library at link and there was an
active forum where people were
discussing these contents and you could
ask there
do you think it is necessary on the
pronunciation of each kanji or learning
the meaning you know learning the kanji
is a bit like learning words
uh when we first meet a word or a kanji
we learn a part of the meaning of that
word a part of how it's used and that's
true in every language and only when we
have then seen that word in many
different contexts do we get a better
grasp of the range of meaning of that
word which words are used together with
it and so on so i would treat the kanji
the same way
i learned kanji in chinese
when i came across kanji in japanese for
the longest time
as when i was reading i would pronounce
it in chinese so i knew the meaning even
if it was a kanji that was pronounced uh
you know
like hashiru
hashiru it's got the o you know and then
it's got the ru or shirou or whatever so
i would still pronounce it chinese style
and after a while i got used to how it's
pronounced in japanese and particularly
if you're doing it on link you can
actually hear it
while you look at it and so you'll hear
different pronunciations of it if you're
listening to the actual
natural voice not the text of speech i
don't know what the text the speech
gives you because i i'm not learning
japanese i like but all i'm saying is
just get a hint
that applies not just to japanese but
any language just get a sense of what
that word some sense of what that word
means which may be relevant to the
texture reading sometimes it isn't and
then you'll come across it again and
again and gradually the meaning
and in the case of japanese the
different readings will fill out your uh
you know grasp of that word
write your interview with pollination i
looked at the world word family sc
reference it looked like up until about
b2 level there were five word types per
word family and a million word corpus
okay i must admit i get confused
sometimes but there is somewhere
a discussion of one point six to one i
don't know quite what it refers to
in any case in any case i think the
discussion of word families and words is
not that useful you've still got to
learn all the words you've got to learn
activity activate action
and they all have slightly different
meanings and i don't see the harm in
treating them all as separate words the
way we do at link
besides which it's it's not possible
always i think there's a lot of dispute
as to whether a word is part of a word
family this word family or that word
family
so to me it's not a big issue either way
so
blah blah blah
i love languages a lot but how can i
concentrate on one and how do i motivate
myself to keep learning that language
you know what
how to not get distracted
is not just a matter of how do you stay
on one language
uh if i'm on my ipad
doing my arabic or persian i can be
easily distracted to go to twitter and
see what people are saying to check my
email you know there's all kinds of
potential distractions
um
but
you just gotta try
it's important
to believe that what you are doing is
important
so if i'm
learning persian and i think i'd rather
be playing golf that's not very good
if i'm learning persian and i think this
is important i like doing it it's a
valuable thing to do i know i'm doing
something useful where i'm going to
succeed it's worthwhile doing i just
stay with it
i'm not tempted to go off and play golf
uh similarly i had to discipline myself
to spend uh you know
three and a half days on arabic and then
three and a half days on persian and not
jump around so
i think you just
create some habits
and tell yourself like be in the moment
i'm happy now i'm learning this language
and i will stay with this language
until a certain point
and then if i decide to go to another
language then i'll say that was the
right decision i don't look back and i
then do this language and i can always
go back to the first language at a later
date
okay
i do you get your motivation i love
languages but i'm lazy good point
we're all lazy i mean we all like to do
what is the least effort to me the
easiest thing to do is to listen
and because i can do it anywhere i can
do it while in the car while jogging
while exercising while cleaning up so
that's easy
and i particularly like a link now where
you can basically listen to the audio of
a course so i just go into my
my ipod
touch here okay little guy that i carry
around with me
i
get the whole course on audio
and as i'm listening there's a bunch of
stuff that i don't understand that i'm
curious about or whatever so that drives
me back into the lesson so i then go and
study the lesson but it's the the
listening is so easy to do and so easy
to find time for that for the lazy
learner
that gets you going now i'm curious and
there is no better period
to learn something than when you're
curious about it
okay so that's my only advice there
um
[Music]
13 hours to
assumes they're active below no i think
that's not fair you don't need
you are not going to activate all the
words that you have passive knowledge of
you need the passive vocabulary in order
to understand what people are saying to
you in order to be able to read watch
movies and and to continue to grow in
the language you need that passive
vocabulary the amount of vocabulary
you'll be able to use in a conversation
is going to be a smaller subset of that
what it is i don't know a third
a fifth something like that
do you recommend to try outputs when
visiting japan even if you haven't
internalized the structure blah blah
blah okay
now you all know that i'm a strong
proponent of input-based learning
but
any opportunity i have to use the
language i use it
so yesterday i went to my local grocer
who happens to be from iran and i tried
to use my persian on him he didn't want
to speak persian with me he said i'm
very good hahaha
i spoke english and then he said but i'm
interested in french so how do i say
this so then we ended up i humored him
in french in other words you can't
control what people are gonna
say to you
uh
but you can always try and i do and i
remember at a very early stage
in my uh russian learning i was at an
airport in amsterdam and there was a
russian gentleman there who was if i
remember correctly he was blind and he
was there was a car supposed to come and
pick him up and he couldn't communicate
in english or dutch or anything and with
my very limited russian i was able to
communicate on his behalf to the hotel
staff so that they could arrange the car
to take him to the airport
there there was no choice he didn't
speak any other language so in a way
from a learning perspective that was
great
so you know i always try to use the
language when i can but i don't
deliberately set up
online conversations until i have a
certain level uh which in the case of
persian has been 3 000 words in the case
of arabic was 6 000 words i used to
think it was ten or fifteen thousand
words now as a result of the many
stories i feel that in most languages
after three thousand words i'm ready to
start once a week
all right
hi steve do books work when it comes to
improving one's active vocabulary i'm
just wondering how many books i need to
read in english to remember at least a
few words okay
i mean you have those words in you those
passive words the only way they're going
to and some of them will bubble up into
your brain
you might say them to
yourself but in order to get better and
better at activating them you have to
speak more and more so the reading and
listening and especially the listening
builds up your potential
in the language but to
get better and better at activating that
in conversation you actually have to
speak more and more
i hope learning languages like you can
give me an advice how long do i memorize
the words my dreams i learn languages in
german spanish i don't memorize all
right i've said this many times i don't
deliberately memorize i don't
deliberately try to remember anything
i trust my brain
because the brain will sort these things
out you just have to give the brain
enough stimulus enough exposure and the
brain will start to slot these things
into place i don't deliberately memorize
i do go over the same material
more than once sometimes many times and
each time i discover new things
uh
and this kind of helps to you know gets
the neurons connecting better but it's
not a deliberate act of memorization
will there here we have how many
countries have
steve any tips on speaking i find it's
extremely
difficult to speak in a foreign language
it's frustrating knowing you have the
words but you can't retrieve them yes
mark that is
an essential part of learning a language
that it is frustrating that we can't
express ourselves as well as we would
like and that will be with you for a
long long time and the only way to get
better is to continue your input
activities and to find more and more
opportunities to speak and to not feel
frustrated when you struggle the main
thing that i want to achieve
is to understand what the person is
saying
then if i struggle it doesn't bother me
what bothers me more is when i don't
understand what the person is saying
is it
will there be a kazakh course on link
and how do i use link properly all right
the languages that we put up on link
it's totally dependent on
what content we receive we can't
possibly go out and create content for
35 odd languages
so if someone is willing to translate
and record kazakh we put it up i mean we
have we have indonesian we have
gujarati we have you know hebrew
languages for which there probably
aren't a tremendous number of learners
so we will put languages up as long as
somebody will create the content
as to how to use link properly there's
lots i'm not going to go through it in
detail here you have to begin by
understanding that listening and reading
are the most powerful most effective
most efficient ways of learning a
language link makes those activities
more efficient and more effective
details on how to use the site are on
the site plus i have a lot of videos
here that talk about it
uh is it essential to visit the country
of the target language and live the
experience with native speakers no it is
not essential
uh i
learned mandarin in hong kong where
there were in the early late 60s there
were hardly any mandarin speakers in
hong kong
we have lots of immigrants in canada who
never learn english or french
so it can help it can help
but you have to be able to take
advantage of it so
the better your level
uh
if you do all of the things that you can
do on your own
you know
input-based learning as i've been doing
say in arabic and persian
now of course there is no country where
they speak fusa that's a bit of a
problem in arabic
but when i was in morocco
and my arabic was a lot poorer than it
is now i was able to speak fusa with
taxi drivers
and uh even though people had warned me
no one in morocco speaks fusa they all
speak their local dialect in fact i
found quite a lot of people did speak
foosa and were happy to humor me
accommodate me to speak with me in uh
arabic even though probably french would
have been a better common language for
us
uh but i had to have some knowledge of
arabic i couldn't just arrive there and
expect to speak i think if i went to
iran if it weren't so difficult to get a
visa to go to iran
uh yeah i would improve a lot i expect
when i go to ukraine in a few weeks here
uh my russian and ukrainian will improve
so being in
where the language is spoken is great as
long as you have a minimum level in the
language
i'm from brazil hello full-time fluency
how is your japanese going blah blah
blah
what are the types businesses where you
or any polyglot uses this knowledge and
what are some career options
uh i don't okay
my japanese was tremendously
uh influential in my business career and
enabled me to
you know connect with
uh
what we call downstream customers in
japan in other words beyond the big
trading companies mitsubishi mitsui and
so forth it enabled me to do business it
helped my career was tremendously useful
for me uh i did business in swedish and
german and spanish
a little bit in chinese
so what languages do for you is it
increases the range of opportunities
that can come your way
life consists of taking advantage of
opportunities the broader the bigger the
net you throw out the more nightlines
you throw out to catch fish
the more opportunities may come your way
and languages increase these
opportunities but i can't tell you of
specific jobs
that require you to be a polyglot
and
what other types of job okay i want
learning is fine that's amazing congrats
you're pretty good as you so far
nothing takes time to build a habit
after a month it was easy to spend an
hour a day learning yeah uh
said absolutely like
it's like going to the gym you know
working out the first couple of times
it's very tough but then you build a
habit and so language learning is like
that you have to get into the habit of
listening and reading and doing those
things do you think bible works well i
have never used babel i can't comment
um i have no idea
bonjour
do i think bilingualism is increasing in
canada
probably no
so let me explain a little bit for those
who aren't familiar with canada
so in the 50s when i lived in montreal
uh montreal
there was a book written called
the two solitudes
so you had one third of the city was
english-speaking and they only met with
each other and two-thirds of the city
was french-speaking and there was a
small area downtown where the two would
meet
and they would meet and it would be in
english so if you wanted to work for a
large company you had to speak english
most english speakers in quebec couldn't
speak french
so this was a tremendous disadvantage to
french-speaking quebecers and yet they
were the majority in quebec
so
the province of quebec the government of
quebec which had prior to then not to
that not even had like the government
didn't even run the education system it
was run by the church until 1960. and so
then uh there was what they called la
revolution
government came in they set up you know
ministry of education
they increased the importance of french
they made it more important to speak
french and quebec the net result was
that some anglophones left quebec
this is all interesting with reference
to ukraine there are language laws
wherever there has been a historical
injustice there will be a revenge and
there will be some language laws and the
net result is that today in montreal
bilingual bilingualism has increased
tremendously and you will meet people in
downtown montreal and you don't know if
they are anglophones speaking french or
francophones speaking english so
downtown montreal is very bilingual i
think it is less bilingual in other
parts of quebec where you will come to
areas where people only speak french
outside of quebec
by and large statistically bilingualism
has not increased and that is in spite
of the fact that the canadian federal
government pours hundreds of millions of
dollars into promoting bilingualism
you know a ridiculous amount of money
like five six hundred million dollars
which goes to teachers and different
organizations and stuff but bilingualism
is not increasing
other than in the case of the french
immersion programs my grandchildren went
to french immersion that means that
anglophone kids in vancouver in
saskatchewan in ontario
they go to school and they study
everything in french so obviously those
kids
who they don't always speak that well
but they all understand
and so they
come through the system having done all
of their schoolwork in french
those people then
become can become bilingual however the
quality of instruction in the rest of
the school system is very poor so very
very few kids coming out of the regular
system
end up speaking french the net result is
that
bilingualism
outside of quebec in other words
anglophones outside of quebec who speak
french is around six percent and it's
pretty well steady and in fact it's
declined it used to be seven and it's
now six and that's despite all the money
that the government spends
now i suggest that in the school system
they should take a different approach
don't
teach like we had in grade 3 the 16
verbs that take
you know i still remember that i
couldn't say anything but i knew the 16
verbs that take it
they've got to have a different approach
and as i've said before they should
encourage people to learn more than one
language focus on comprehension which is
essentially what the french immersion
program does because they don't speak a
lot of french in class but they end up
with good comprehension skills and if
people have good comprehension skills
they can learn the language so that's a
long-winded answer to the question from
galileo steve i saw the video let you
speak arabic i've got to say your
performance was amazingly impressive
here in the preview blah blah i suppose
go ahead thank you ahmed i appreciate it
i always accept any compliments or words
of encouragement and it's very important
not only for me but for everyone
don't criticize people
where you can encourage them because we
thrive on that that makes me more keen
to study arabic
most english speakers don't have a 30
000 active vocabulary if you think you
do you're in la la land yeah we don't
use that many words active although
passively we could have even more words
how do i not get shy from talking to
native speakers and stop switching to
english posts
how do you not get shy
don't worry about it i mean it's
difficult it's that people have
different personalities i find that the
better i understand the more confident i
am so if i don't understand then it's
very hard if i have good comprehension
i'm prepared to go with it
well i don't know any japanese just
cantonese and spanish i'm just gearing
up to tackle mandarin okay
for the person that's researching german
i recommend nico's web okay that's good
really i found your chance
since i didn't really know how to stop
on my own okay when i started it's a
long journey blah blah blah i really
enjoy your videos if you had any advice
on utilizing i have no advice i uh
question on utilizing a language
textbook i mean i use textbooks mostly
for content and if they have grammar uh
drills i don't do them
uh if they have
audio with some grammar you know
examples like the best way to learn
patterns in a language is to hear a lot
of examples not to do tests
that's what i would suggest
hello from uzbekistan where i'm
currently on vacation good i can read
sentence in foreign language i can ask
foreign speakers many things a story but
i never understand what they reply
yes that's why you focus on
comprehension first the most
uncomfortable feeling is not
understanding what people say it's not
struggling to say something and if you
understand well if you have good
comprehension you will be able to speak
eventually
uh how are you liking uzbekistan blah
blah blah steve what do you think of the
method called suggestopedia never heard
of it
uh blah blah blah now it's
boy
difficult for me to read the arabic on
the fly like this i've never been in
this place blah blah blah what does it
mean to be functional a language be two
guys like
are
can you reach native fluency you live in
mainland china for a year only if you
study living there won't do it for you
um
scott preston i met dr lozanova and i
write a book for mankind research the
teacher-oriented system still used
learning from a textbook ridiculously
story for 98 of people steve has it
right make learning fun for you borah
was filmed in romania has no kazakh i
mean yeah i mean borat has nothing to do
with kazakhstan kazakhstan kyrgyzstan
that's all
turkic
speaking
uh
call it you know
sort of it's that central asian divide
between
uh
asian like mongolian and turkic and
different shades of all of that i don't
know much about it but it has nothing to
do with borat's film however funny it
might be how come you struggle to
understand
japanese tv after four favorites how
come i just do it's difficult difficult
tv is difficult you're not in that
environment it's not a familiar
environment they're speaking quickly
i could
have business conversations but i didn't
fully understand the tv programs
uh
can i reach fluency you're doing it okay
at that i'm going to cut it off here
again i want to work a bit on my persian
so i can warm up for my tutor
and so the last of these sessions will
be on monday i'm going to review my
statistics i'm going to get your
reactions to the experience for you
and i look forward to our next meeting
bye for now